Pastor Greg Locke the pastor's got some
egos huh threatened to expose the six
witches who are members of this church
here we go we got first
and last names of six witches
there you go there that everyone should
be going like this okay we gotta go we
gotta go I mean dude imagine like the
seriousness he's saying look this is the
next thing this is what you hear after
this this is what yeah first
and last names of six witches grab my
purse we gotta go that are in our church
and you know what strange three of you
are in this room right now hat no
they're not dude there are not three of
you witches of the six witches in the
room right now because there are not
witches in this room because there are
not witches we all know that
let's continue
[Applause]
dude
hahaha
then when he [__] did the microphone
and the thing dude unbelievable that's
the most dude that hop was so [__] dude
have you I mean I can watch it dude wow
man we gotta say that again I'm gonna
see that we got to see the whole lead up
the most a [__] hop of all time well
hops are always [__] honestly for real
but Jesus Christ this [__] ass and how
he tapped the [__] Podium oh my god
dude I live for [__] like this dude
we got first feeling himself last name I
love it because he's going like this you
know what dude I know what I'm saying is
controversial and the mainstream doesn't
understand that there's witches and they
might be sniffing out some insecurity on
my end so what I'm going to do is double
down on it be so confident and and so he
starts speaking with such utmost
confidence it's a little bit carried
away and Taps the podium well does a
[__] [__] hop and that's when the
inner [__] is exposed the inner [__]
is always exposed if you're sincy it's
coming out if you're from Cincinnati you
could go to any state you want but you
can't remove the Cincy from yourself
and that's on God
or six witches
come on we gotta watch it from the
beginning dude first
and last names are six witches
that are in our church here we go and
you know what strange three of you in
this room right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
three of you in a room right now oh
you better look at my eyeballs we ain't
afraid of you you stinking witch you
devil worshiping Satan is a witch we
cast you out in the name of Jesus Christ
we break your spells Slipknot break your
curse we got your first name we got your
last name we even got an address for one
of you
didn't know how to end it
unbelievable dude why is he wearing a
[__] Hogwarts shirt dude unbelievable
why is he from hot Hogwarts
is he from Slytherin dude this is the
guitar is in the back you know dude this
whole clip is [__]
unreal dude the [__] that's the most
[__] [__] I've seen in 2022. and and
I'm saying hands down that's on god dude
let's see the rest of it I I watched the
beginning of it and I saved the rest of
the podcast because I want to get the
honest reaction Stan you stinking witch
hates his words into this church to
destroy us
to lure Us in you were sent to this
church to cast spell this also also also
dude the three of the people that are
the witches they don't even know they're
the witches
everyone's just looking around like I
wonder who he means and it's one of them
is you uh
dude so focused on getting these through
which is also where are the other three
witches
get to get them all
don't be so [__] is it lackadaisical
or lackadaisical yeah someone you've
been sick cause you've befriended that
witch
two of you in my wife's ladies Bible
study and you know who you are and we
gonna ask you to get out
ah dude they [__] he flirted with him
and she told his wife about it and now
he's [__] doing it like this
oh dude and two of them said about my
wife's Bible study and then well you got
to get out dude he flirted with him
because he said well boy he said don't
those because this is what he said to
both of them and it didn't work well
don't those hush puppies look nice in
that shirt
oh my God oh my God and then the other
one went oh my God and then [__] he's
like well you're witches and everybody
we got all six of their names okay say
them oh
two of them had already been confirmed
well that thing ever even said it no I
hate the two of them so much
holy [__] this guy's on fire
oh because one person yeah first at last
more is more disrespectful to call her a
chick like that then [__] call her a
stinking witch
you got a choice
you can leave with your spells all by
yourself
or I'll show up next Sunday
with a stage full of brooms
and I'll give you one and I'll fly your
tail up out of this place in the name of
Jesus but we ain't playing your spell
casted witchcraft nonsense sage burning
games
everybody okay
the witches are like nope
and your little dog too you're out witch
wow dude that guy had the [__]
greatest childhood of all time and just
thinks everything he says is so dope
dude it's so bro the [__] first of
all don't need a stage full of brooms
you know if there's only six of them
just bring that and only two showed up
bring two
unbelievable what do you say here at the
end though
games
everybody okay
knows you went too far the witches are
like nope
stand up and your little dog too you're
out we're chilling it
unbelievable dude
this guy is just
who are The Witches can you tell us
who are the people that believe this
you're out
who is this guy Greg Locke
uh dude if I were there I swear to you I
would stand up and be like yo I'm one
what if he was just like we don't want
you here get your spells out of here and
I'd be bowling Allah and a [__] light
beam just was coming out of his mouth
dude then I would then I would believe
there were witches there